this episode of real science is brought
to you by curiositystream
watch dozens of space documentaries and
get free access to nebula for just
14.79 a year by signing up at
curiositystream.com
real science venus
the second planet from the sun and
sometimes referred to as earth's twin
nearly the same size with about the same
mass and both with significant
atmospheres
the two planets seem like they should be
very much alike
but in spite of their similarities venus
is a toxic hellscape in comparison to
earth
temperatures can reach more than 400
degrees celsius
and the pressure there is staggering
it's more than 90 times higher than on
earth
standing on the surface of venus would
be like standing 900 meters below the
ocean surface
in terms of pressure and all this
pressure and heat
is due to its monstrously thick
atmosphere
kilometers of the greenhouse gas carbon
dioxide
with poison clouds made of sulfuric acid
the crushing pressure and immense heat
make venus a particularly hard place to
explore
well we have heard many stories about
mars rovers we've never heard about a
venus rover because there's never been
one
the longest mission to the surface of
venus was a stationary lander that
survived for only two hours
it's so hot on the surface there that
metals like lead would completely melt
and the pressure is so high it could
crush a nuclear submarine
so the idea of any life being there has
always seemed far outside the realm of
possibility
its extreme environment has caused most
scientists to set their sights elsewhere
when searching for extraterrestrial life
planets like mars or jupiter's moon
europa or saturn's moon enceladus have
taken center stage in the search
but for decades other experts have
postulated something different
that life may indeed be possible on
venus
not on its sweltering surface but within
its thick clouds
in 1967 carl sagan wrote while the
surface conditions of venus make the
hypothesis of life there implausible
the clouds of venus are a different
story altogether
and now 53 years later scientists may
have found
the first sign of this hypothesis being
true
phosphine gas detected in extremely high
levels in the atmosphere of venus
phosphine gas doesn't sound like much of
anything to most of us
but it has scientists around the world
extremely excited
is there reason to be excited what is it
about phosphine gas
that could indicate life and how could
life even be possible in such an extreme
environment
phosphine gas is a substance that we
know of as something to be avoided here
on earth
it's a colorless flammable very toxic
gas
with the chemical formula ph3 it was
used as a chemical weapon during world
war one
and is used today as an agricultural
fumigant
it's also a poisonous byproduct of meth
labs
hence walter white's heavy-duty hazmat
suit it's a dangerous substance that
seems antithetical to the idea of life
as we know it
but phosphine can be a byproduct of life
specifically by some species of
anaerobic bacteria
organisms that live in environments with
no oxygen
such as marshes landfills or inside
animal guts
and unless we humans have manufactured
the phosphine
the only way we know of that it can be
made on rocky planets like ours is from
these microbes
for this reason earlier this year
scientists determined it to be an
appropriate biosignature gas
biosignature gases are ones that are
produced by life
and accumulate in an atmosphere to
detectable levels
and help guide scientists in their quest
of looking for life on other planets
on earth the majority of life is
centered around oxygen
it's a byproduct of photosynthesis and
it's subsequently used by other forms of
life to breathe
methane and nitrous oxide would also be
among earth's biosignature gases
but scientists are aware that focusing
on these gases alone would be a very
earth-centric approach
alien life could very well exist in
non-earth-like environments
such as a place with no oxygen and just
like in the anaerobic environments
within earth
a planet with no oxygen could still
produce phosphine as a sign of life
and making phosphene an even more
compelling biosignature is the fact that
it doesn't form easily
when investigating a potential
biosignature scientists have to be
careful to consider
all other possible origins of the
biosignature in question
something like methane or oxygen in an
atmosphere could plausibly be explained
by a number of chemical processes
but phosphine it takes extremely
specific thermodynamic
conditions for it to form outside of
biological life
it needs extremely high temperatures and
plenty of elemental hydrogen
scientists don't know of any way
phosphine can be produced on a planet
that is less than 527
degrees celsius the gas giant jupiter
for example has high levels of phosphine
gas
it forms there in the hottest deepest
layers of the atmosphere
where hydrogen is abundant but on rocky
planets like earth and venus
lower temperatures pressures and
hydrogen quantities in the atmosphere
make phosphine gas an almost impossible
presence
so when researchers pointed their array
of telescopes called alma at venus
they almost could not believe what they
were seeing
alma can detect the energy emitted and
absorbed by any phosphate molecules
spinning in the atmosphere
and what it detected was far more
phosphine than even exists on earth
20 parts per billion versus earth 7 or
so parts per trillion
if phosphine really is in the atmosphere
of venus
then its presence indicates something
extraordinary happening
either something is creating phosphine
on venus in an unanticipated
chemical event or alien life is
producing phosphine gas as a byproduct
just like the anaerobic bacteria on
earth
one event is obviously more
extraordinary than the other
but scientists are now scrambling to
figure out which one it is
to understand how life may have started
on venus
let's consider how it started on earth
for decades
scientists have debated the origins of
life and it's largely still shrouded in
mystery
however most theories do include a
common set of environmental conditions
considered
vital for life liquid water needed to
dissolve
molecules to facilitate chemical
reactions mild temperatures
needed because temperatures higher than
122 degrees celsius destroy
most complex organic molecules a process
to concentrate molecules
needed to take the diluted organic
compounds in the environment and bring
them together
a complex natural environment with a
diverse range of temperatures ph levels
and salt concentrations
needed to create the chemical complexity
that life requires
and trace metals needed to promote the
formation of organic molecules
when looking at this ingredient list it
seems rather unlikely that venus could
actually give rise to life
its surface temperatures of over 400
degrees celsius means that no liquid
water can be present
and the heat would also break down any
organic molecules
however like carl sagan postulated in
the 1960s
if you go up to the middle of the cloud
layer on venus
temperatures and pressures become rather
earth-like
water droplets could form and electric
discharge in the clouds could possibly
lead to the formation of organic
molecules like methane
and perhaps there life could indeed form
but this theory falls apart pretty
quickly when you consider what these
clouds are made of
sulfuric acid this hyper-acidic
environment would break down
any free-floating organic compounds so
with its extremely hot surface and hyper
acidic atmosphere
venus today is no place for life to form
but this may not have always been the
case
recent computer modeling shows that
early venus was very similar to early
earth
with shallow oceans and mild
temperatures for up to two billion years
of its early history
scientists simulated conditions of a
hypothetical early venus with an
atmosphere similar to earth's
a day as long as venus's current day
spinning once for every 117 earth days
and a shallow ocean consistent with
early data from the pioneer spacecraft
the study also factored in an ancient
sun that was up to 30 percent dimmer
because of the slow spin of venus its
dayside is exposed to the sun for almost
two earth months at a time their
modeling showed that on an early
oceanic venus this could have warmed the
surface and produced
rain that created a thick layer of
clouds which acted like an umbrella to
shield the surface from much of the
sun's heat
some nasa scientists think this means
that venus's early temperatures could
have
actually been a few degrees cooler than
earth's today
and under these conditions perhaps life
could have formed
some researchers are proposing that if
the phosphine detected in venus's
atmosphere
is a sign of life that this life is a
relic of a previous biosphere
an ancient remnant of a once thriving
ecosystem that eventually collapsed due
to the runaway greenhouse effect that
created
present conditions if life formed back
then
it might have adapted to spread into the
clouds when intense climate change
boiled the oceans away
killing the rest of the biosphere
microbes in the clouds may have become
the last
survivors on venus and while life
existing
suspended in clouds seems unheard of
it's an idea that is actually not so
alien to life here on earth
in 2005 researchers used a balloon to
collect samples from
different levels of earth's stratosphere
at heights ranging from 20 to 41
kilometers
and in all 12 bacterial and six fungal
colonies were detected
since then microbes from every major
biological lineage have been detected in
earth's upper atmosphere
this strange microbe behavior could
perhaps then also be plausible on venus
but this still doesn't address the
extremely acidic conditions in the
clouds of venus
and its lethality to life as we know it
even the most durable extremophiles that
live in acidic conditions on earth
can withstand only around 5 acid
the conditions in the clouds of venus
are over 90
acid this by the way is also why we can
rule out the idea that any of our venus
probes accidentally dropped off these
microbes
anything from earth could not survive
there but just as life has moved into
every nook and cranny on earth
from hot springs to volcanic fields
maybe the same can be true on venus
and the organisms have adapted to the
acidity the supposed alien life living
in that environment would have to exist
in some form
unknown to us either somehow
withstanding or protecting their carbon
bonds from the acid
or existing as non-carbon-based
life-forms with different chemical bonds
altogether
but before we can get too excited about
the idea of phosphine indicating alien
life
scientists still need to rule out any
other possible chemical reaction
happening on venus
that could lead to the production of
phosphine the researchers carefully
examined other possible origins of the
gas
like a chemical reaction driven by
lightning volcanic activity
or delivery by meteorites they noted
that while lightning can occur on venus
it happens much less than on earth and
would fall short of producing the energy
required to create phosphine
they also estimated that there would
need to be more than 200 times as much
volcanic activity on venus as on earth
to inject enough ph3 into the atmosphere
to be detectable
and while there are thousands of
volcanoes on venus as far as we can tell
none of them are active a recent study
found a few that may be dormant
not dead but in general there is not
enough volcanic activity going on to
account for the phosphene
and even if every single one of those
volcanoes was active
the researchers believe that the maximum
production of phosphine by volcanoes on
any planet
even ones with tons of hydrogen is at
least seven orders of magnitude lower
than the surface fluxes required for
detection
and assuming venus receives the same
amount of meteorites as earth per year
this would deliver a negligible amount
of phosphorus
such meteorites contain an average of
0.25
phosphorus by weight and even
conservatively assuming that a hundred
percent of that phosphorus could be
hydrolyzed
ph3 these meteors would deliver a
maximum of around 10 tons of ph3 every
year
not enough to account for what was
detected on venus
scientists simply don't know of any way
phosphine can be produced on a planet
with these temperatures and pressures
and with limited hydrogen but this
doesn't mean it's impossible
even the authors of the paper say that
they emphasize that the detection of ph3
is not robust evidence for life only for
anomalous and
unexplained chemistry other scientists
doubt that the phosphine detection
itself is even real
the signal detected was faint and an
extensive amount of processing was
needed to pull it from the data returned
by the telescopes
that processing could have returned an
artificial signal at the same frequency
as phosphine
however the researchers have repeated
their findings on two different
telescope arrays
the james clerk maxwell telescope and
alma
and found a nearly identical pattern of
detection
there is certainly enough here to be
excited but perhaps just not about alien
life just yet
if the researchers can confirm the
phosphine detection beyond a shadow of a
doubt
and they continue to not be able to
explain it
the next step will have to be sending a
spacecraft to venus to check out exactly
what is going on
collecting samples of the gas or even of
the possible alien life
as carl sagan once said extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
and as the planetary science community
sets its priorities for the next decade
of space
exploration venus has just rocketed to
the front of the list
if you're like me all this talk about
space in the news and the possibility of
life on other planets
has reignited a curiosity that i had let
dwindle over time
it's something we grow up intrinsically
excited about and then life inevitably
gets in the way
it's been a while since i've laid in the
grass and looked up at the stars and
really let the incredible weirdness and
vastness of it all sink in
but since wrapping my head around what
this phosphine discovery on venus means
i have nothing but the urge to drive
away from the city lights and do just
that
i think learning about space and
understanding the significance of recent
discoveries
can let the curiosity buried in us start
to come out again
so if you need a break from our current
reality want to ponder the vastness of
the universe
or perhaps reignite a lost interest in
the cosmos
you should check out the space
exploration documentaries on
curiositystream
this eight-part series called the
planets made by the bbc
in particular is one to add to your
binge list
the episode called giants for example
explains the one discovery that made the
dream of a flight to the giant planets a
reality
and shows how scientists navigated what
seemed impossible
sending the voyager probe billions of
miles from earth to get a closer look
at the outermost planets of our solar
system curiosity stream has so many high
quality documentaries like this
on any of the subjects you want to learn
more about and to make it even better
curiosity stream has partnered with
nebula nebula is a streaming platform
that i helped make with some of the best
educational content creators
like real engineering wendover
productions tierzoo and polyphonic
it's a place where we can experiment
with content without worrying about the
youtube algorithm
nebula allows us to take our time
producing content
and open so many creative doors because
of this
there is a range of awesome content you
can find there original long-form
documentaries
or as of recently a new section for
original podcasts
like the show makers podcast where in
the latest episode
brian from real engineering and sam from
wendover productions interview me
about my scientific and creative
background so if you sign up for
curiositystream at
real curiositystream.comrealsci you'll
get a subscription to curiosity stream
and a subscription to nebula for now
just 14.79 a year
26 off the usual price by signing up
you're not just supporting this channel
but all of your favorite educational
content creators
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
instagram twitter and patreon are below
[Music]
you